how was this project the record-keeper
the best thing that happened to and then
possibly I would the worst thing yes
that's funny yeah I call I've referred
to record-keeper as the best worst thing
that's ever happened to me it's on one
hand it was incredibly creative and
wonderful I met so many great artists
from that but that was a work-for-hire
that project it was I was working for a
big organization they wanted to make
this thing at the beginning it was to
promote this book they're very
conservative organization they're a
religious organization so they had
certain judgments about film and movies
being there you know this is a religious
organization that doesn't you know no
drinking no dancing you know very very
conservative
well they ultimately didn't like the
product at the end even though I tried
to warn them about what it might look
like this is a big lesson for me about
making sure that everyone understands
what this ending product will be before
it's finished that's that's a challenge
well they did ended up not releasing it
and it was a big controversy within
their organization about whether or not
they should release it and it got ugly
it was my first experience with things
like negative press where my name is
mentioned in press in certain circles
about controversies and things high-end
political things I mean we're not
talking national political things but
within their organization like being
caught up in some of that like I I mean
I know that filmmakers on a level
projects can have this happen but I'd
never experienced no one ever trained
you for that kind of thing how you react
when the public is watching and it was
very painful because we threw everything
into that I personally just put my whole
life on the line for this project and it
was something special like we created
something very special like we all knew
it walking around on set you could feel
electricity while we were filming these
scenes people just like this is the
coolest thing we've ever seen and then
it you know because we all felt like we
were on this launching pad and
doesn't come out it ended up getting
leaked it's it's you know it's found its
way out there it's but it's never been
officially released it has played in
festivals but the the stain of never
having it out there which of course you
know from a simply an investor
standpoint for future jobs they look at
this as well you've never made a film
that's gotten distribution or at least
they're talking about that one it's like
it reflects negatively on me which is
it's not even my fault right so that was
a real challenge it it ended up like
being so discouraging that I considered
maybe not doing film anymore like I
thought maybe this isn't right for me
these are the things they don't tell you
about in film school like on on the
utter disappointment that can happen and
sadly this happens all the time and not
just this it's you can't blame this
organization for that it what happens in
a level movies all the time all the time
read like read stories of Joss Whedon
and how much he struggles you know with
a lot of the projects he does shows that
get cancelled when they're halfway
through it happens all the time there is
no manual for how to deal with some of
that where you you've sacrificed and
fought so hard for something that that
everybody hates or or whatever or the
certain political people or powerful
people who decide not to release it or
butcher it re-edit it and put it out in
a way that you didn't like that's why
they have directors cuts that was a real
challenge in it it there was a lot of
lessons to be learned about I think the
temptation is to not put so much of
yourself into things I don't feel like
that's correct I think that's that's
what made the project so special is by
how much I put in because it's also at
magnetic across people to it but I think
the lessons I learned from that were
communication
[Music]
every time I've been in some sort of
conflict usually unset it becomes it
comes down to the fact that of
communication someone didn't understand
something that was supposed to happen
and the frustrating part about film
sites sometimes you have to say it 50
times because someone's on their phone
and someone's not listening so was not
up to speed something I thought we were
doing this you know that's where all the
conflict starts in this case it was a
little bit of the client not
understanding the vision even though I
tried to explain it as clearly as
possible if they still did not quite get
it so it just underscored how important
it is that everyone knows what they're
getting and that as a filmmaker it makes
me I have to make sure to do things like
mood reels or photos of the character
like this is kind of an idea of what I'm
looking at or any anything you can do
because remember I am a visual person
but they may not be they may respond to
text they may respond to sounds more
than you know you have to you try to
utilize all the senses to make sure
everyone gets the vision and if it's a
problem let's talk it out before we get
to the end because that's where the
problems happen for us
yeah and just sometimes once your
project is over you just have to step
away from it and let it be what its
gonna be because it was easy for me to
be angry at the fact that it wasn't
released but what if I choose to do that
I miss the blessing that I got out of it
of because it wasn't released it got
more attention than it ever would have
and it got me to places that you know
like I did a worldwide festival tour on
it because they they just allowed that
because I wasn't making money on it but
they did allow that because of the
controversy if they had done if that had
not happened they would have sold it and
probably would have disappeared on
Amazon or something so it got way more
publicity that never would have before
that's a really good thing that's a
that's a great thing
yeah it just was and I'm still learning
lessons from that it's and it's kind of
incredible to me the people who were
touched by that film I've still get
people emailing me about things they saw
in it and how it moved them and how many
times they've watched it and they don't
have DVD they deserve it they're just
finding remnants on YouTube that are out
there like yeah and I this underscores
also the power of storytelling because
it was because the story was told well
it caused a deep emotional reaction from
people both on both sides both good and
bad the people that fought for it
vehement ly fought for it and it got
ugly the people who fought against it
feelingly fought against say my god I
like it was just was a crazy experience
like crazy if a filmmakers in a similar
situation what would your advice be to
them well so yeah conflict and this kind
of thing I would love to tell you that
it's it's uncommon if that's happened on
all sorts of levels right like it could
be a client video an instructional video
for the smallest of client they you turn
it in and they don't like it or they
change the edit like you know or it
could be in the huge national level I've
had both and you have to be so careful
with how you react because when you're
making art and I don't care if it's a
wedding video or the feature film with
your dreams you're gonna have an
emotional attachment to it for me I have
to make sure that I take a minute before
I respond sometimes especially if I'm
very if I find myself really angry and
frustrated sometimes I need to I need a
way today before respond or not not fire
back that text like because the this is
I cannot underscore how important this
is how you react to bad news will
determine if you work with them
again if if you blow your top and say
ugly things because it's so tempting
sometimes they will probably say okay
well we're gonna hire someone else next
time you know even though that situation
is frustrating you still we saw all need
to work and you know there may be a lot
of positive things that could happen
from ex-client right so yeah being
careful about your responses and
sometimes sometimes I'll have other
friends read an email response to make
sure it doesn't sound mean you know this
is where being a pro comes in to things
like I had a client one time that I
finished the product I handed it to him
they didn't like it they wanted to cut
out a big middle piece this is a
narrative thing for corporation and I
got so angry about that like I was I was
really upset about it
so in my own in my office a place that
the client never visited I read I got to
make a duplicate of my timeline in the
edit machine and I called it you know
castrated version well and I'm thinking
well no one's gonna see that well when I
exported the video it automatically
titled it that I didn't catch that and I
sent it to the client this is a one
there's a huge mistake like it's
embarrassing to talk about because
fortunately the guys that saw it was
like oh that was a nice little jab
little barb you know I changed the title
for before I said to Tom see ya thank
God he did that but you have to be so
careful with that stuff about things you
say and who you're saying it to and
where that might go this is where being
vent to your partner vent to your
buddies don't vent to your clients
and to those decision makers yeah that's
that's tough I mean kids look it look it
I mean I think a good example is josh
trank i think his name we did fantastic
for remember when that movie was coming
out and how he tweeted negative things
about the film
right before it was released and it
turned out to be this big thing that he
was now black bald like that is such a
lesson for filmmakers on yeah maybe he
had good reasons to be upset but boy you
take it to Twitter
that's a don't do that that you can't
take that back
that's out there that can like that can
ruin your career that can make you that
kind of thing can make you move to
another city like yeah so easy you have
to watch yourself on that
you